vorrei che questo momento non arrivasse
mai non hanno coniugato per niente il
verbo vorrei che questo momento non
fosse mai arrivato eravamo rimasti
ragazzi che ma l'hanno fatto su questo
livello qua devo cambiare la testa la
via di nuovo nel prossimo livelli cosa
devo fare
clicca sulle ballerine di click sulle
ballerine cellemme dovrebbe essere
quindi scorso esattamente allora fermi
un attimo che qua è per veri
videogiocatori altro che god of war
aspetta un attimo dovete fare il verso
della gallina per forza quando non
capisco mi girano le palle quando non
capisco però ve lo dico chiaro e tondo
in genere se clicchi due volte o ecco
cos'è che dovrebbe essere stati sa
quanto brutta farle vedere tu che di
cosa sia capace zia sapevo mettevo
martin garris però completato e l'ex
questi sono tutti me e me che io non
conosco e probabilmente neanche voi
tanto perché è vestito come un ladro il
commesso
c'è una cacca qua al nuovo vista mille
barca era
ma non avevo letto i nomi dei giochi
minecraft half life 3 e batte il toro ha
cominciato continuato a sbagliare perché
non capisco cosa devo fare e posso
pregare è di melo che ne so la nora che
quest'anno scannerizzato io da solo va
bene dovevo intuirlo ragazzi next
smetteranno prima o poi riusciresti
giochi speriamo di se questo è un tutti
i memi che comunque non conosco ma vabbè
mi sento molto più intelligente adesso
bene sbuffare il kraken sea of thieves
quale avevo a che era era chiaro e sono
scemo io
next baby bella casa è questa mi sembra
easy sarà che devo toccare è andata a
fuoco
occhio occhi si bene l'ho fatta
no che strano sarà che devo certa chi è
chi sta tizia a los ormai me le
divisioni del sorridi sorridi far ciò
accade di sorridere
esatto eccolo questo vorrei conosciuto
un memo quanti livelli ho fatto 20 21 21
livelli un meme ho riconosciuto un meme
sui social parrucchino come minimo tipo
antonio conte che se credevo fa ad
organizzare carta ghanese non va bene
sono sul tizio non era esattamente
quello che volevo fare volevo zoomare
mag ok anche così
è come basta come lei è mia intortato
tutto un momento che doveva esserci tipo
un jump schermo no mi pare che il limite
sia 32 quindi mancano dieci livelli
giusto la madonna molto grosso ciao mi
prendi il gatto grazie
basta sentire non andava fatto così è
costato fare scusa ti posi da avvicinare
per forza a ok perché c'è una calca
effetto lancia il gatto nel canale ancia
meno il canestro chiarissimo ma questo
stesso questo meme che voi sappiate no
perché non me ne intendo io ho studiato
nella vita prendi la carta igienica le
banane non le prende l'aspetta prendi a
banana emo sei triste perché si chris se
cioè tutti gli ingredienti che volevi
piccati tu nel carrello lo sapevo ha era
la lava gialle non tace e floris lava
non mi ricordavo più nome credo sia la
floris credo è poi non so però comunque
il primo tentativo non riesco ma io ti
dovevo provarci al primo tentativo
maledizione batman non l'ho mai non
mangiare non mangiare aspettati no dai
pipistrelli morti che non è male perché
si è spaventato i soliti fanno schifo
la madonna stai calmo però osceni avanti
fatti in quanto preso male inaspettato
riuscì a primo tentativo primo tentativo
il non li voglio indizi curtis tua mamma
di vuole indizi gratis
niente è rimasto su indizi che non li
voglio gli indizi gratis rimaneva skate
cup se devo schiacciare fortissimo tutte
le volte che devo
no ci ho provato che la vacca o eccolo
li mortacci sua lo sapevo che era uno di
questi cosi non poteva riuscirci prima
cosa è stata una gamba
cos'è ne avanzi l'a26 devo riuscire a
fare il primo tenta di primo tentativo
frega niente
dopo di togliere indizi gratis mi dà
fastidio non rimanere lì fino alla fine
o arco sono fatto subito trovata subito
la cacca ci ho fatto subito stavolta ti
prego no perché cavolo è riuscito a far
la cosa giusta subito no devo levare i
calzini cavolo ce l'avevo fatta stavolta
no non ci credo
dai cd provo a queste qantas rai non ho
sbagliato a fare un mai a fare un
livello del primo tentativo impossibile
ve lo giuro raga impossibile una
scoraggiato della sinfonia a ok
chiarissimo st livello fantastico no
anche mese gli altri fossero chiari però
chi vuole essere trono lollo la domanda
da un milione di troll e trololo allora
potrò trono tro lolo lo trovo lo trovo
ha detto veramente lo trovo lo salverà
sarà lo lo l'on
e anche quello sì però di mico la
risposta giu secondo me non è allora
scommetto che devo cambiare il
presentatore mettere gerry scotti cav h
eccolo è lui ma li mortacci solo clicca
e si era un casino non è stato
impossibile a vincere subito
questo voglio schiacciarlo più che
finire subito livello no no no no no no
no vabbè allora hai migliorato tanto
queste peanut butter gelli fermati
fermati park cavalca fermati ma la canna
minestra resca fantasy e lo scrittore
qualcosa che non vedo anche qua però
madonna cosa è successo perché perché
non mi fa chicca ma la donna se
intrippato tutto il telefono alla porta
di una vacca marta maledizione quanto
difficile fu fermato confermato come ho
fatto
abbiamo fermato ma iniziate oriente ci
ero riuscito non so come o starnutire
fortissimo cav h bene più starnuti che
sono picchiati evidente quando stanno
disco che era la dice lunga quanto
fossero intelligenti meme un po di tempo
fa non che adesso siano migliorati però
quella over gli attacchi a tecnici lui
air france perché sicuramente la barca
c'entra qualcosa fermi tutti no non
riuscì a vincerne un altro tentativo
nesi ha fatto per terra pestano festa la
festa è stato pestato la pesca l'ottimo
altri ma pestano inizio al pesto o ci
voleva un ora per testarlo ho detto ho
detto un'ora fa
mancano due livelli ragazzi ciò solo più
questo e quello dopo che l'ultimo di
trophies che poi abbiamo finito per
provare a vincere il primo tentativo è
difficilissimo questa è fra i giusto 300
400 gratis gratis 100 100
no no perché ma dai pensiamo sia giusto
non vuoi soldi
era gratis pro c900 e verde è vero che
diversamente dagli altri indici 900
centra amica a metà ci vado per cento
nel senso me né dai metà pieni che gli
offro perfetto beh è un affarone dai
metà cosa chiara ultimo livello si come
l'ultimo non ce la farò mai a farla
primo tentativo però ci provo lo stesso
ma devo ammettere la soluzione non so
neanche come scriverle quelle cose che
mi che ci sono scritte lì come alza la
mano cav h non fa niente
vabbè dai perdiamo 1 up su digitare asi
triplo 7 trono lollo lollo sbagliato e
te pareva triplo setter viso set
praga non lo so ma che che poi il prof a
quello che vuoi corsa e vabbè a perché
faccio una soluzione impossibile è stato
risucchiato tutto il mondo esiste tra il
fisco stv show e ce n'è un altro
l'ho fatto tv show di mi disse ti prego
farwell sono riuscito a finire tra mi
sento una persona intelligente perché
finire questi giochi è sinonimo di
intelligenza tutti abbia finiti anche
young signorin spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cosi semplice comunicato che
apriva gente notizia iscrivetevi se non
siete iscritti e non ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]